it's a hard job man it's not easy it at
all it comes with so much responsibility
that's my double dates like yeah so do I
it's draining I think the groom should
always tell the best man what is my
specs I would say if you're gonna write
a speech as a best man make it not the
traditional you know he's always loved
make it about experiences make it about
history make it about that person and
what you see out of them and why they
love this person and don't eat a bad
joke won't be to any of the bad joke the
guy that starts off with a bad joke
hello I'll get everybody's attention
yeah this reminds me of to tell him the
bubby shh don't say driving a bad joke
what well this is an upsetting story we
talking about Nancy's again you remember
that right Bobby yeah that's me get to
anything but Ty's I whenever I get a
tire I'm like really I gave when I was
the best man I gave number a car key he
opened up these like you got me a car no
it's just my keys I'm gonna see what you
do that funniest thing ever look at I
got to be kidding me this bro the sadies
VidCon she kept no no no not it is mine